to
to return to uh the world of lisp for
a brief moment you uh at cmu you've
you uh wrote a version of emacs that
that i think was very impactful on the
history of emacs
what was your motivation for for doing
so
at that time so that was
in like 85 or 86.
um i had been using
unix for a few years
and um most of the editing was
this this tool called edie um
which was sort of an ancestor of vi
and is it a pretty good editor
not a good editor well if if what you're
using
um if your input device is a teletype
it's pretty good yeah it's certainly
more humane than tico
which was kind of the the common thing
in
a lot of the dec universe at the time
tico is both tk is that the no tico
t-e-c-o
the text editor and corrector corrector
so many features um
and the original emacs um
came out as so emac stands for editor
macros
and tico had a way of writing macros
and so the original um
emacs from mit sort of started out as a
collection of
macros for tico but then
you know you know the the sort of emac
style got
got popular originally at at mit
and then people
did a few other implementations of of
emacs
that were you know the the code base was
entirely different but it was sort of
the philosophical style
of the original emacs what was the
philosophy of emacs and by the way were
all the implementations always in c
and then no and how does lisp fit into
the picture
no so so the very first emacs was
written as a bunch of macros
for the tico text editor wow that's so
interesting
and the the the macro language for tico
was probably the most ridiculously
obscure
format you know if you just look at a
tico program on a
on a page you think it was just random
characters
it really looks like just line noise
so it's kind of like latex or something
oh worse
way worse than they take way way worse
than latex
um but you know if you use tico a lot
which i did the tico was completely
optimized for
touch typing at high speed
um so there were no two character
commands
well there were a few but mostly they
were just one character so every
character on the keyboard was a separate
command
um and actually every character on the
keyboard
used usually two or three com commands
because
you know you hit shift and control and
all of those things you know it's just a
way of
very tightly encoding it and
mostly what emacs did was it made that
that visual right so
one way to think of tico is use emax
with your eyes closed
um where you have to maintain a mental
model of
you know sort of a mental image of your
document you have to go
okay so the the cursor is
between the a and the e
and i want to exchange those so i do
these
these things right so it it almost it is
almost exactly the emax command set
well it's roughly approximate roughly
the same as emacs command set
but using emacs with your eyes closed
um so what
emacs you know part of what emacs added
to the whole thing was
was being able to visually see what you
were editing
um in a form that matched your document
um and you know a lot of things
changed in the in the command set it
um you know because it was programmable
it was
really flexible you could add new
commands for all kinds of things
and then people rewrote emacs
like multiple times in lisp there was
one done at mit for the lisp machine
there was one done for multics
and one summer i got a got a summer job
to work on the pascal compiler for
multix
and that was actually the first time i
used emacs
and and and so to write the compilers
you worked in compilers too it's yeah
that's fascinating
yeah so i did a lot of work you know
i mean i spent like like a really
intense three months
working on this pascal compiler um
basically living in emacs and it was
it was the one written in mac list by
bernie greenberg
and i thought wow this is a just a way
better way to do editing
um and then i got back to cmu
where we had kind of one of everything
and two of a bunch of things and four of
a few things
and um since i mostly worked in the unix
universe
and unix didn't have an e-max i decided
that i needed to fix that problem
so i so i wrote this this implementation
of emacs in c
because at the time c was really the
only language that worked
on on ux on unix
um and you were comfortable with c as
well oh yeah at that point
yeah at that time i'd done a lot of c
coding that this was in like 86.
um and
you know it was running well enough to
be for me to use it to edit itself
within a
month or two and um then it kind of
took over the university and and then
spread
and then yeah and then it went outside
and largely because unix kind of
took over the research community
on the on the on the arpanet
then and emax was
was kind of the best editor out there it
kind of took over and
there was a actually a brief period
where
i actually had login ids on every
non-military host on the on the arpanet
you know because people would say oh can
we install this and and i'd like
well yeah but you'll need some help
uh the days when security wasn't uh when
nobody cared nobody cared
you